in a Tel Aviv drug lab medical marijuana
is getting a
makeover ground and filtered it's
destined for a new 3D printed pot
puffing device that won't get you high
we've developed the the first meter dose
cannabis inhaler which allows 100
microgram resolution and all this while
using the raw cannabis without any
chemical alterations or additives which
allows us to penetrate existing
regulatory systems today so no expensive
clinical trials no more guessing how
much cannabis a patient needs to relieve
their pain the devices they're making
here in Psy lab are destined for Israeli
hospitals but they hope the real money
spinner will be this it's a cannabis
inhaler for home use they hope to have
it in Israeli homes next year and into
the all important American Market the
year after that market already worth
about $1.4 billion could rise to more
than 10 billion by 2018 psyche hopes to
win about 2% of that or some $200
million but does the inhaler actually
work David M A former Navy SEAL injured
in Lebanon was one of 10 Israeli
patients to trial
it I'd spend whatever it takes to have
this device doesn't show everyone else
how much I'm suffering or what I'm using
lets me decide how to take care of my
health and be much more relaxed on the
outside the doctor overseeing the psyche
Tri says the device could change
marijuana's image doctors were reluctant
to prescribe cannabis as is as
cigarettes because of the stigma because
of the uh actually you need to smoke for
that I think that uh from now on once
approved everybody is going to look at
it as a medicine as opposed to a
substance that people use with approval
in Israel imminent psyche aims to raise
up to $20 million to boost production of
its device if all goes well it plans to
apply its technology to other Controlled
Substances such as
opium